l'egypte
désert infini
terres solitaires qu'une étroite bande
de verdure et d'eau traverse dans un
contraste saisissant
de ses rives surgissent les merveilles
d'une civilisation qui prospérera
pendant plus de trois millions
[Musique]
une simple plaque de schiste exhumé des
sables témoigne du tout premier des
pharaons
[Musique]
vieille de plus de 5000 ans cette
palette de narp maire nous entraîne sur
les traces de l'egypte antique bien
avant que n'apparaisse le premier
d'entre eux
[Musique]
l'egypte antique saga captivante d'une
civilisation qui s'étend sur 18 dynastie
ou lignée royale
[Musique]
né sous le règne du pharaon djoser air
sous l'ancien empire d'égypte l'art des
pyramides se transmet se perfectionne
pendant plus de quatre siècles avant de
disparaître
l'egypte dé premier pharaon vénère tout
un panthéon de dieu animaux en même
temps qu'elle entretient une croyance
complexe en la vie après la mort
hatshepsout première grande région de
l'histoire fait édifier à deir el bahri
l'un des sites religieux les plus
grandioses de tous les temps avant qu'on
ne cherche après sa mort a effacé toute
trace de ses réalisations
puis c'est au tour des hyksos venus
d'asie de conquérir l'egypte avant de se
voir repoussé par le fier peuple
égyptien une lutte qui s'étend jusque
sous la coupelle du roi amosis qui
proclame avec la xviiie dynastie le
nouvel empire
[Musique]
l'egypte désert infini terres solitaires
qu'une étroite bande de verdure et d'eau
traverse dans un contraste saisissant
[Musique]
de ses rives surgissent les merveilles
d'une civilisation qui prospérera
pendant plus de trois mille ans une
simple plaque de schiste exhumé des
sables témoigne du tout premier des
pharaons
[Musique]
vieille de plus de 5000 ans cette
palette de noir maire nous entraîne sur
les traces de l'egypte antique bien
avant que n'apparaisse le premier
d'entre eux
[Musique]
l'egypte antique saga captivante d'une
civilisation qui s'étend sur 18 dynastie
ou lignée royale
[Musique]
né sous le règne du pharaon djoser sous
l'ancien empire d'égypte l'art des
pyramides se transmet et se perfectionne
pendant plus de quatre siècles avant de
disparaître
l'egypte dé premier pharaon vénère tout
un panthéon de dieu animaux en même
temps qu'elle entretient une croyance
complexe en la vie après la mort
hatshepsout première grande région de
l'histoire fait édifier à deir el marie
l'un des sites religieux les plus
grandioses de tous les temps avant qu'on
ne cherche après sa mort a effacé toute
trace de ses réalisations
puis c'est au tour des hyksos venus
d'asie de conquérir l'egypte avant de se
voir repoussé par le fier peuple
égyptien une lutte qui s'étend jusque
sous la coupelle du roi amosis qui
proclame avec la xviiie dynastie le
nouvel empire en 1386 avant jésus-christ
la civilisation égyptienne fait déjà
deux mille ans d'une histoire qui aura
vu défiler quelques 86 pharaons
c'est à cette époque que le jeune et
dynamique eurois amenhotep iii qui
devient aménophis iii monte sur le trône
[Musique]
lorsque le pharaon aménophis iii arrive
au pouvoir
l'egypte est déjà un empire prospère et
stable les richesses affluent en
particulier vers la famille royale
l'image de ce pharaon et par conséquent
étroitement liée à celle d'une égypte
culturellement et architecturalement
très développé
[Musique]
ces grands projets de construction se
concentre sur l'ancienne ville de thèbes
sa décoration du magnifique temple dédié
au dieu amon demeure l'un des sommets de
l'art et de la technique de la
civilisation égyptienne
sa vaste cour et ses gracieuses colonnes
en font un chef-d'oeuvre d'esthétique et
d'architecturé
sur la rive ouest du nil trônent deux
imposantes statues figurants aménophis
iii
aux 18 mètres ces deux colosses de
memnon sont les seuls vestiges du temple
funéraire que le pharaon s'était fait
construire ici
[Musique]
tout près de lui minuscule en proportion
se tient une représentation de la reine
tiyi sa femme et la mère de leur fils
l'egypte grâce à ses importantes
expéditions commerciales conduite à
l'étranger ainsi qu'à ses abondantes
réserves d'or en provenance des mines de
nubie vie à cette époque des jours riche
et prospère
c'est une période à laquelle les
égyptiens trouve le temps de se poser
toutes sortes de questions d'ordre
théologique qui vont les mener à une
situation qu'ils qualifieront eux-mêmes
de désastreuse
le désastre en question survient en 1353
avant jésus-christ sous la forme d'un
homme à l'apparence physique bizarre et
en qui certains voient un hérétique
[Musique]
alors kévin office 3 avait préparé son
fils aîné à lui succéder
ce dernier décède
m
son jeune frère aménophis iv prend sa
place
[Musique]
son éducation exclusivement religieuse
le démarque catégoriquement de la
tradition politique bien ancrée des rois
égyptien au point que les spécialistes
s'interrogent toujours sur la nature
profonde du personnage etait-il
simplement un fanatique ou au contraire
un grand réformateur un visionnaire ou
plutôt un fou
son mysticisme en tout cas le fait
passer pour le plus insolite de tous les
pharaons
alors que sur plus de dix sept siècles
les égyptiens ont été habitués à vénérer
plusieurs divinités différentes
aménophis iv impose d'emblée un dieu
unique et suprême le dieu solaire à
temps
[Musique]
pour asseoir davantage encore sa réforme
du culte il se fait appeler akhenaton
celui qui plaît au dieu attend
[Musique]
c'est la toute première fois dans
l'histoire de l'humanité qu'on exige
d'un peuple qu'ils s'en tiennent à un
seul le bouleversement est tel que
l'egypte en est ébranlé jusqu'au plus
profond de ses racines son règne marque
l'une des grandes crises de l'histoire
d'egypte
c'est une période à laquelle on renverse
les vieilles croyances on déplace la
capitale et l'ont fermée lieux de culte
cela fut sans doute très dur à vivre
pour la population
le village de carnac élevé sur les
ruines de thèbes demeure le plus vaste
ensemble d'édifices religieux au monde
c'est là qu'on couronne akhenaton
pharaon en 13 150 avant jésus-christ au
cours d'une cérémonie traditionnelle
[Musique]
une tradition qui s'efface cependant au
fur et à mesure que de grands
bouleversements se profile à l'horizon
tout commence avec l'extension et
l'embellissement du temple d'amon à
carnac
[Musique]
en y installant dans l'enceinte de son
règne un disque solaire symbole du
nouveau dû à ton akhenaton impose ce
dernier comme le seul et unique dieu
officiel de l' empire
[Musique]
on l'a parfois qualifiée de premier
monothéistes de l'histoire dans le sens
où il a volontairement évincer la
croyance dans d'autres dieux pour ne
privilégier que l'adoration de son
disque solaire on retrouve cet
anticonformisme dans le choix de sa
reine néfertiti issu d'une famille noyal
elle n'en joue pas moins un rôle capital
dans le règne de son épouse
l'une des représentations sculptées les
plus admirables jeu m'a mise à jour en
egypte n'est autre que le buste de
calcaire de cette reine légendaire
[Musique]
l'idée maîtresse de ses représentations
et de montrer une femme extrêmement
belle et séduisante
on ne sait pas en vérité si c'était le
cas mais il s'agissait de la présentée
d'abord comme l'incarnation suprême de
la voter justifiant comme pour tout
autre reine qu'elle soit la partenaire
idéale du roi si l'on nous montre une
néfertiti idéalement mail la nature a en
revanche pourvu akhenaton d'un physique
tout aussi étrange que ses idées
dès le début beaucoup de ces effigies
sème la confusion parmi les archéologues
en effet il apparaît souvent avec des
hanches larges un ventre et un poitrine
proéminente
au point qu'on a parfois émis
l'hypothèse d'une femme travestie en a
pourquoi pas on peignait bien la reine
hatchepsout sous les traits d'un homme y
compris affublé de la barbe postiche
réservé au roi sans doute pour insister
sur le symbole viril du pharaon
on a parfois attributs l'apparence
physique d'akhenaton au syndrome de
babine ski frolik cette maladie de
l'hypophyse s'illustre entre autres par
une obésité typiquement féminine en
particulier du tronc et de la racine des
membres la stérilité figurent parmi les
autres effets secondaires de cette
maladie or nous savons que néfertiti et
akhenaton eu plusieurs filles
certains pensent même que toutankhamon
était leur fils il ya donc très peu de
chances pour qu'il était atteint de ce
mal
[Musique]
on n'a jamais retrouvé la momie
d'akhenaton aussi ces suppositions ce
fontaine uniquement sur les
représentations graphiques et sculpté du
pharaon
d'autres spécialistes penche plus
volontiers pour une interprétation en
rapport avec sa nouvelle religion fondée
sur le dieu solaire à ton
[Musique]
mon point de vue est qu'il incarne les
caractéristiques physiques de cette
divinité at on n'est pas juste le dieu
solaire c'est aussi le créateur
or dans la mythologie égyptienne le
créateur est à la fois masculins et
féminins
la nouvelle religion d'akhenaton est une
véritable entorse à la tradition mais sa
conviction est tel qu'il s'est mis en
tête de défier et de supprimer les
puissantes institutions religieuses
représentant les croyances de
pratiquement toute la population
il commence par fermer les temples aux
diamants et destitue thèbes de son rôle
de capitale sa religion justifie à elle
seule une ville nouvelle qu'il compte
bien faire bâtir
[Musique]
lan nous 344 avant jésus-christ marque
l'aube d'une ère nouvelle à 305
kilomètres en amont du caire dans une
vaste ans de falaise dans un côté
bordent le nil surgit sous la pulsion
d'akhenaton la nouvelle capitale de
tellal amarna
[Musique]
bien qu'elle ait été détruite il ya fort
longtemps les spécialistes ne le
décrivent comme un exemple unique
d'urbanisme aux édifices somptueux
entouré de large bassin et de riches
jardin on pense même qu'elle aurait
abrité un zoo
le pharaon baptise sa nouvelle ville
akhenaton qui signifie l'étendue sur
laquelle rayonne le dieu solaire
au centre de la ville s'élève le grand
temple dédié tout entier à l'adoration
du dieu at on
avant sa réforme du cube la population
ordinaire pratique est à l'extérieur des
temples dont les salles secrètes et
obscures étaient réservées aux offices
du roi des prêtres une l'élite
akhenaton décide que dorénavant le
commun des mortels célébrera son dieu en
sa compagnie en plein air et sous les
rayons vivifiant du soleil
probablement trois cérémonies ont lieu
quotidiennement au grand-angle la
première à l'aube lorsque le soleil se
lève sur les falaises à l'est de la
ville
[Musique]
la seconde à midi avec le soleil au
zénith
et enfin à la tombée du jour avec la
déclamation par les fidèles d'un
cantique au soleil composé par akhenaton
lui même
au toit qui par-dessus l'horizon monde
si magnifiquement vers les cieux aux
attendes qui vit et répand la vie dès
que tu pointes envisage depuis l'horizon
est d'inonder les terres de ta beauté
toute entière
[Musique]
on ne connaît pas le succès réel de
cette conversion forcée des fidèles ou
tu as ton
il est possible que cette nouvelle
religion n'était qu'un simple stratagème
visant à renforcer la puissance du
pharaon en faisant table rase des autres
dieux
akhenaton savait en effet qu il se
hisserait lui même davantage à l'image
d'une divinité
[Musique]
le roi a fait un grand ménage
il a balayé toute la hiérarchie des
prêtres et le fouillis encombrants de
centaines de dieu différents il n'a
laissé à leur place qu'un culte tout
simple et avec lui suffisamment d'espacé
pour s'imposer lui-même comme une
divinité vivante
[Musique]
cependant akhenaton d'endosser seul la
fonction de guide spirituel sa femme
néfertiti l'assistent hâtivement au
quotidien néfertiti joue là un rôle
capital
on ne sait pas si akhenaton lui a confié
une part de ses responsabilités ou bien
si c'est elle qui se les est attribué
certains égyptologues ont d'ailleurs
toujours considéré que c'est surtout
néfertiti qui tirait les ficelles de
cette réforme religieuse
la reynerie mère d'akhenaton est un
autre personnage important
elle a suivi le pharaon vers sa nouvelle
capitale pour lui servir
vraisemblablement de régente
[Musique]
avec un fils aussi absorbé par la
question du culte il est en effet
possible qu'elle se soit chargé des
affaires de l'état
de curieuses tablettes d'argile envoyé
au pharaon akhénaton laisse à penser que
ce fut le cas rédigé dans l'urgence
depuis les avant postes militaires de l'
empire égyptien en syrie elles font état
de l'imminence de leur capitulation face
aux attaques répétées de laigné plus
connu sous le nom de lettres d'amarna
elle implore le pharaon de dépêcher du
renfort contre la promesse d'une
fidélité absolue
là où le moindre pharaons aurait très
certainement répondu par l'envoi de
troupes
la probabilité veut que la reine tiyi et
tout simplement ignoré ses appels au
secours
[Musique]
l'expression artistique pictural de
l'époque subit elle aussi un
bouleversement partout le pharaon
apparaît désormais sous la protection
des rayons du soleil
alors qu'on avait toujours présente et
les pharaons sous des traits physiques
parfait akhenaton ordonne à ses artistes
officiels de le dépeindre d'une manière
aussi réaliste que possible
ainsi on ne montre plus à guerrier viril
mais un personnage féminin
un père proche de ses enfants
un époux tendre avec sa reine autant de
scènes beaucoup trop intime et
inimaginables à peine quelques années
plus tôt akhenaton et néfertiti
gouvernent ensemble 12 ans curieusement
on perd toute trace de la reine au delà
de cette période après avoir agi
pratiquement en cours et chante d'égypte
elle se volatilise mystérieusement sans
même qu'un document écrit au picturale
ne témoigne de son sort
sa disparition fait encore débat
aujourd'hui
[Musique]
elle pourrait être morte en accouchant
on a également suggéré une quelconque
imprudence ou indiscrétion de sa part au
point qu akhenaton est éventuellement
chercher à se débarrasser d'elle à moins
tout simplement qu'elle ne se soit
laissé absorber toute entière par son
culte du soleil
[Musique]
il est en effet possible que plus des
votes encore que son époux elle est fini
par se cloîtrer dans l'adoration
exclusive du dieu attend
[Musique]
beaucoup plus simplement elle est
probablement morte
on sait en tout cas qu'elle a été
enterré dans la tombe royale d'amarna en
dehors de la ville quoi qu'il en soit
akhenaton ne demeurent pas longtemps sol
il nomme un nouveau cours et jean du nom
de semaine car dont certains pensent
qu'il s'agit peut-être de son frère
cadet
on suggère aussi qu'il a pu épouser une
ou plusieurs de ses propres filles ce
qui ne serait pas franchement étonnant
de la part d'un fait rare mais on
raconte aussi qu'akhenaton a peut être
eu une relation homosexuelle avec son
corps et gens vers la fin de sa vie ce
qui dans la mesure où il aurait eu des
enfants de néfertiti en ferait l'un des
premiers grands personnage bisexuel
son apparence physique pour ainsi dire
peu catholiques et sa démarcation
radicale d'avec les religions
traditionnelles on poussait histoire à
le cataloguer parmi les hérétiques
tout porte à croire d'autre part que son
culte du soleil et finalement fait peu
d'adeptes parmi la population
les fouilles de la ville antique
d'akhénaton ont permis de constater que
la plupart des habitants avaient
conservé chez eux les idoles de leurs
nombreuses divinités alors que leurs
pharaons était encore au pouvoir avec il
tout simplement pressenti le caractère
éphémère de cette nouvelle religion
[Musique]
l'adoration du disque solaire ne survit
pas à la mort d'akhenaton en 1334 avant
jésus-christ
la réaction est même extrêmement
brutales ont détruit systématiquement
tout ce qui se rapporte à son nom
sol ses partisans craignant le pire
s'empresse de déplacer son corps de la
tombe de tela la marne à
[Musique]
la coutume voulait qu'on se rassemble
pour organiser soigneusement la mise en
lieu sûr de la dépouille des pharaons
importants de sorte qu'ils puissent
passer tranquillement à la postérité
c'est certainement ce qui a dû arriver
pour akhenaton
ça laisse d'ailleurs aux archéologues de
belles perspectives de découvertes
l'egypte se cherche alors un pharaon
capable de restaurer la foi et de
regagner la confiance de son peuple
mais la responsabilité fini par tomber
sur un jeune garçon d'à peine dix ans
[Musique]
derrière la barrière des falaises de
deir el bahri dans la zone montagneuse
située à l'ouest de thèbes se trouve une
région de ravines et de lit de rivière
asséchée que l'on appelle des oasis
[Musique]
les égyptiens du nouvel empire enterrent
leurs pharaons au milieu de ces canyon
dans une vallée que l'on appelle la
vallée des rois
[Musique]
c'est là que par un après-midi de 1922
de notre ère une découverte ressuscite
de l'oubli des sables le nom d'un
pharaon supposé de moindre importance
[Musique]
il apparaît peu à peu que ce roi du nom
de toutankhamon n'est autre que le fils
de l'hérétique akhenaton on commence à
comprendre pourquoi ce dernier était
resté jusque là pratiquement anonyme
les égyptiens en voulant effacer toute
la mémoire d'akhenaton en ont peut-être
fait autant avec celle de son fils
la liste des rois sur les murs d'abidos
est effectivement curieusement amnésique
quant à l'existence de ces deux pharaons
les spécialistes de l'egypte se penche
dès lors sur une toute nouvelle et
passionnante question qui était donc ce
toutankhamon
ouais
il
[Musique]
toutankhamon est né et a grandi dans la
capitale d'amarna après la mort de son
père son prénom d'origine tout en carton
ou image vivante du dieu solaire at on
devient toutankhamon alors que la
population nous volontiers avec ses
anciennes traditions et le culte du dieu
amon
une simple lettre change et le nom du
jeune pharaon retourne ainsi à l'image
vivante du dieu de ville de nouveau les
oeuvres d'art le représentant d'un roi
vaillant lancé à l'attack de l'ennemi du
bien et syriens
les experts quant à eux demeurent
sceptiques quant à l'implication réelle
d'un si jeune pharaon dans des campagnes
militaires
tout porte à croire en effet que les
responsabilités de commandement était
confiée au général aurait même un
ambitieux guerrier que les documents
retrouvés décrivent comme le commandant
en chef de l'armée et vice roi avec pour
mission de rien imposer aux pays voisins
la suprématie militaire du royaume
aurait même s'est illustré par sa longue
expérience au service des deux pharaons
précédent toutankhamon plus dont se
place mieux que lui pour incarner le
pouvoir à la cour d'un enfant roi un
enfant poussé sur le trône et dont on
estime qu'il n'est qu'un souverain
fantoches
la réponse doit probablement se trouvait
chez un homme dans la forte personnalité
éclipse celle des autres membres de la
poule haye dont le nom signifie perd
10-20 les autres que le vizir et grands
prêtres du roi c'est un fonctionnaire
habile et déterminer les égyptologues
pense qu'avec horemheb haye tire les
ficelles du pouvoir et permet à cette
époque à l'egypte de rester un pays
stable aurait même et est sont tous deux
adeptes du dieu amon c'est sous leur
impulsion que le pays se débarrasse du
dieu solaire à ton et revient aux
anciennes croyances basées dans
l'ancienne ville de thèbes
c'est à dire maintenant louxor bien
entendu toutes les inscriptions de
l'époque continue de faire les louanges
de toutankhamon mais en vérité ce sont
en coulisses les bureaucrates les
fonctionnaires le général aurait même et
le grand prêtre et qui gouverne le pays
et à pose partout où il le faut les
tampons officiels
[Musique]
on continue de s'interroger sur
l'investissement réel des pharaons dans
la politique extérieure et dans les
affaires intérieures de leur pays
l'egypte dispose en effet d'une
véritable bureaucratie d'administrateurs
et de script
le pharaon est avant tout le chef de
file royen les religieux comme ses
prédécesseurs le jeune toutankhamon voit
sa vie orchestrée par une série
d'activités de cérémonies destinées
simplement à le renforcer dans son titre
ce jeune roi est d'abord une personne
qu'on s'attache à couvrir en permanence
les symboles de la royauté on l'assist
du moment où ils se lèvent au moment où
ils se couchent son champ d'action est
finalement très restreint et les
affaires de l'état ne l'intéresse pas
vraiment il doit juste avoir envie doté
sa couronne ainsi que tout l'apparat qui
marque ses prérogatives pour s'en aller
jouer avec ses camarades
toutankhamon a déjà sa reine
de deux ans son aîné elle est aussi la
fille d'akhenaton une épouse et par
conséquent une demi soeur elle
s'appelait amundsen patène et c'est
devenu encaissé namo ils se sont mariées
très jeunes et semblent être restés très
proches l'un de l'autre comme dans ses
représentations où on la voit face à lui
qui s'intéresse de près à ces activités
de chasse ou de pêche après le
rétablissement des anciennes religions
on s'attend à ce que l'egypte vive sous
le règne de toutankhamon une période de
renouveau les 18 ans le jeune pharaon
meurt subitement certains pensent qu'on
l'a assassiné
l'analyse médico-légale de sa momie
montre qu'il a succombé à un traumatisme
crânien comme si un coup violent lui
avaient été portés à la tête
or d'une expertise plus poussée laisse
apparaître un simple petit trou dans
l'os
on imagine dès lors plusieurs hypothèses
d'abord pensé qu'on l'avait poussée de
son char ce qui est assez improbable vu
la nature de sa blessure
ensuite qu'on l'avait assassiné dans son
sommeil à l'aide d'un objet pointu
d'autres ont préféré imaginer qu'il
était peut-être mort d'une hémorragie
cérébrale
y at il eu conspiration pour le tuer
certains suggèrent que sa boîte
crânienne aurait été transpercée
qu'après sa mort on sait que les
embaumeurs ne faisait pas toujours très
attention au corps qu'on leur confiait
on sait par exemple que pour faire
rentrer la momie dans son cercueil
il leur arrivait de couper les pieds et
les placer à côté
je pense qu'il s'est passé quelque chose
de ce genre avec toutankhamon
je ne crois pas qu'il soit mort d'un
coup à la tête mais ce sont plutôt les
embaumeurs les responsables de cette
blessure
cette mort prématurée ne laisse pas à
ces ouvriers le temps de lui bâtir une
tombes royales digne de ce nom
c'est probablement la raison pour
laquelle on demeure en cash et le site
funéraire de toutankhamon parvient à
échapper aux pillages sont entrés
restera en effet longtemps obstruées par
des fragments de roches et les versets
la plus tard au cours de travaux d'une
autre tombe royale
avant la découverte des trésors
stupéfiants de toutankhamon le monde
moderne devait s'en tenir à une
évocation purement imaginaire des objets
d'art et temple richement coloré de
l'ancienne egypte
la mise au jour du tombeau du jeune
pharaon permettent ainsi de constater
tout l'opulence et la magnificence de
l'époque
[Musique]
reste à confirmer si ces richesses
accompagnant vers l'éternité un
souverain relativement peu importants ne
sont encore que proportionnelle à celle
des tombes des grands pharaons
[Musique]
certains historiens prétendent qu'il ne
faut pas s'attendre à davantage de
miracle avec une population si
reconnaissante pour la réhabilitation
des anciennes religions et l'émotion
soulevée par un décès aussi prématurée
il est probable que les funérailles de
toutankhamon était déjà des plus
fastueuses
[Musique]
une mort précoce qui non seulement prend
de court les ouvriers du roi mais laisse
une fois de plus l'egypte sans héritier
du trône
[Musique]
on sait pourtant que le jeune couple
royal a tenté de prolonger la ligne et
deux foetus momifié ont été retrouvés
dans la tombe de toutankhamon
ce sont très certainement les restes de
petites filles mort né
[Musique]
la théorie de certains égyptologues veut
que les unions consanguines cumulée aux
maladies aux guerres de l'époque et
contribué au déclin de certains règne
dans le cas de toutankhamon il semble
que cet enfantement consanguins est tout
simplement rendu ces créatures trop
fragile pour qu'elle survive
[Musique]
comme il n'y a aucun successeur légitime
on confie par défaut l'autorité du pays
aille grand vizir de toutankhamon des
documents montrent que juste après la
mort de son souverain aille se seraient
préparés à prendre pour épouser la jeune
veuve du pharaon
afin de renforcer sa légitimité au trône
celle-ci suspectant la complicité die
dans la mort de son mari aurait tenté de
fuir ce mariage les espérer la jeune
encaissé nam on aurait réclamé de l'aide
à l'étranger en écrivant au roi des
hittites
[Musique]
envoyez moi l'un de vos nombreux fils
que je puisse l'épousé afin qu'il
devienne roi je n'ai personne ici
c'est le roi des hittites a répondu à
son appel
en envoyant l'un de ses fils seulement
il ne faut pas oublier la connivence qui
existe à l'époque entre les bureaucrates
et les deux grands gouverneur en place
le général aurait même et le grand
prêtre et est à peine arrivée aux
frontières d'égypte le prince it it a
été assassiné
[Musique]
ainsi en épousant la veuve de
toutankhamon à 1325 avant jésus-christ
aille se proclame souverain avant même
qu'on ait achevé la sépulture du pharaon
défunt en atteste une peinture retrouvée
dans cette tombe où on le voit coiffé de
la couronne bleu des rois présidents aux
funérailles de toutankhamon
[Musique]
peut-être à y était-il eu de toute façon
destiné à succéder à toutankhamon
un doute subsiste cependant aussitôt
après kai est accéder au trône
on perd toute trace de la reine encaissé
naba
celle qu'on surnommait princesse
d'amarna et reines du destin disparaît
subitement
at-elle été elle aussi victime d'une
conspiration à il ne règnera que quatre
ans comme toutankhamon il n'a aucun
héritier susceptibles de perpétuer cette
xviiie dynastie aussi le trône passe
bientôt entre les mains d'une nouvelle
lignée de roy très dynamiques parmi
lesquels figure le plus connu de tous
les pharaons celui ci marque le début
d'une ère de construction et d'expansion
jamais égalée en même temps qu'il pousse
à l'extrême l'image divine du pharaon
[Musique]
l'ancienne ville de thèbes
les pharaons se plaisent dans ces
paysages qui bordent le nil
[Musique]
c'est là que la reine hatchepsout a fait
dresser son obélisque et camino fils 3 a
bâti son grand temple à la gloire du
diamant
la situation de cette capitale au sud de
l'egypte illustre le choix naturel d'un
pays expansionniste qui cherche à
s'étendre notamment vers les riches
terres de nubie
[Musique]
avant de mourir toutankhamon ya
réinstaller sa cour royale
ces deux là aussi que son successeur et
vizir à y aura gouverné fussent même
brièvement
[Musique]
en 1321 avant jésus-christ c'est au tour
du général aurait même de se proclamer
pharaons des hautes et basses et gîtes
horemheb signifie au russe en pleine
d'allégresse divinités égyptiennes à
tête de faucon l'oiseau de proie aux
russes incarne le dieu des rois
aurait même monte sur le trône après une
longue et brillante carrière militaire
débutée sous aménophis iii soit 4 règne
auparavant akhenaton l'a nommé chef
suprême des armées et tout en gamme en
vie ce roi
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
n'étant pas de sang royal aurait mais
ben ne peut prétendre au trône cependant
il choisit de se créer un vague lien de
descendance en épousant la soeur de
néfertiti
[Musique]
comme il n'est plus extrêmement jeune il
s'empresse d'abord de ramener l'egypte à
la situation précédant la période dite
d'hérésie introduite par akhenaton à
thèbes
il ferait ouvrir lé temple d'amon afin
d'éviter un conflit de pouvoir avec le
clergé
il nomme ses propres prêtres issus de
l'armée en qu'il place toute sa
confiance
il détruit ensuite les grands temples
qu'akhenaton avait fait édifier amarna à
la gloire du disque solaire
il en récupère les milliers de blocs de
pierres pour les murs et pylônes ses
portes flanqué de tous en rectangulaire
de ses nouveaux projets de construction
il est loin de se douter que quelques
trois mille ans plus tard ses efforts
pour effacer la moindre trace du règne
d'akhenaton auront un effet complètement
inverse que découvrent les archéologues
alors qu'il travaille à la restauration
et à l'étude de ces vieux monument il
met tout à coup au jour ces milliers de
blocs corée mais ben était convaincu
d'avoir enterré pour l'éternité
il découvre en fait des scènes décrivant
la vie d'akhenaton et de son culte csn
qui ont été enterrés longtemps sont en
définitive mieux conservées que celle de
la vie dorée même aurait même usure
également de nombreuses statues et
monuments de ces derniers prédécesseurs
pour cela il lui suffit de faire graver
son nom à la place du leur
ainsi la plupart des égyptologues estime
que deux statues retrouvait à carnac
serait en réalité d'après les traits
caractéristiques du visage celle de
toutankhamon
si cette pratique semble révéler une
dose certaine néocentrisme il faut
pourtant savoir qu'elle est courante
chez de nombreux farah je pense que les
égyptiens ne voyait pas ça sous un angle
forcément négatif à leur sens
il s'agissait même plutôt de recyclage
quelque part ça faisait aussi partie des
prérogatives du nouveau souverain en
montant sur le trône il héritait de
fonctions divine
ayant toujours existé c'était donc sa
manière à lui de s'accorder avec
l'éternité et de signifier au peuple
qu'il avait toujours été là
[Musique]
aurait même reste au pouvoir pendant
près de 30 ans à sa mort en 1306 avant
jésus-christ on le maudit à son tour
pour ne pas s'être assuré de descendants
légitime afin d'éviter le chaos autour
de sa succession
il a tout de même désigné son vizir
comme futur s'ouvre à un roi qui en
prenant le nom de ramsès premier
inaugure la 19ème dynastie tout en étant
loin de se douter qu'elle restera parmi
les plus grandes épopées de l'histoire
d'égypte ancien officier de carrière
ramsès premier devient pharaons alors
qu'il est probablement dans un
cinquantaine il veut lui aussi
poursuivre la reconstruction de l'egypte
et bien qu'il ne reste que deux ans au
pouvoir
il parvient à accomplir ce que ces trois
derniers prédécesseurs n'ont pas fait
engendré un fils héritier
[Musique]
le fils de ramsès premier se nomme seti
dont le nom rappelle la dévotion de sa
famille audio 7
sous le règne éphémère de son père il
s'est vu décerner le titre de vizir et
de chef des armées
après avoir hérité du trône il s'octroie
le titre supplémentaire de régénérateur
des naissances afin de souligner l'aube
d'une nouvelle ère dont ils se portent
garants sous son empire
la culture et l'art se développe
considérablement
il lance en même temps de vastes
chantiers de construction comme à carnac
où il commence à faire édifier la
célèbre salle hypostyle du temple d'amon
ou quelques cent trente quatre colonnes
répartis sur 5400 six mètres carrés
il entame une vague de restauration et
d'accroissement du site religieux
d'abidos effet bâtir son temple
funéraire à gourna autant d'efforts
qu'ils l'aident à légitimer son droit à
la couronne malgré le fait qu'il ne soit
pas de sang royal
la cité de bidos est dédié au culte
d'osiris le dieu des morts c'est
nécropole des anciens pharaons des deux
premières dynasties tombe en ruine
le temple que c'est ea premier se fait
construire à cet endroit est considéré
comme l'un des grands chefs-d'oeuvre de
l'époque
à l'intérieur il apparaît représenté aux
côtés de nombreux dieux égyptiens
on pense effectivement à l'époque que
les dieux réside là où on leur a dénié
un temple
[Musique]
ces reliefs mais euros figure parmi les
plus beaux d'egypte sculpté avec la plus
grande minutie et selon les techniques
les plus perfectionnés il se différencie
des sculptures habituels les plus
rudimentaires de l'époque
c'est aussi dans ce temple que l'on a
découvert la fameuse table d'abidos
liste que ces types premier fait graver
en hommage aux pharaons qu'elle
considère comme les plus importants
c'est-à-dire de ménez a lui même
c'est ici ni fils du dieu cette la
divinité des tempêtes et de la guerre
sur les champs de bataille
le phare on se montre à la hauteur de
son nom ci aurait même s'est chargé de
rétablir les anciennes traditions
égyptienne sethi 1er se préoccupe de
restaurer à l'étranger le prestige du
pays ainsi que de reconquérir certaines
régions éloignées de son vaste empire
notamment le levant après sa bataille de
kadesh en asie
c'est un roi qui a été élevé dans une
culture militaire
il va entreprendre quatre campagnes
contre les hittites et repousser une
invasion libyenne à l'ouest le temple de
karnak figurent parmi ses plus grandes
réalisations le long du mur nord vous
avez ces immenses et l'on relief qui le
représente
attaquant les forteresse ennemie on a là
véritablement un guerrier puissant
[Musique]
après treize années d'un règne
particulièrement fécond sethi 1er c'est
un an 1278 avant jésus-christ
o lantern à bord dans le tombeau qu'il
s'est fait construire dans la vallée des
rois avant de déplacer sa momie vers une
sépulture secrète creusés dans les
falaises surplombant le temple
d'hatchepsout tu adhères el bahri ceci
afin de lui épargner un éventuel
pillages
[Musique]
ce n'est effectivement qu en 1881 que
des archéologues mettent au jour sa
tombe et découvre parmi 160 me
la sienne qui restent de surcroît la
mieux conservée de toutes les momies
royales
[Musique]
la première épouse de cetti et la reine
thuyas elle aussi est issu d'un milieu
militaire sans aucune origine noble
si leur premier fils meurt et que leur
second enfant est une fille
le troisième va devenir le souverain le
plus célèbre d'égypte
l'étoile sirius de la constellation du
grand chien est aussi celle qui brille
le plus dans le ciel égyptien elle
disparaît chaque année au début du mois
de mai pour réapparaître vers le 18
juillet son retour marque pour les
égyptiens anciens le début de la saison
des crues ou le nil dépose alentours
selim en fertile
[Musique]
une année sous le règne de cetti ces
crues sont particulièrement importantes
la légende veut qu'elle annonce
l'avènement du prochain souverain
celui ci n'est autre que ramsès ii dont
le nom deviendra presque à lui seul
synonyme de pharaon
un succès qu'il doit peut-être à la
préparation consciencieuse à laquelle
son père sethi 1er l'astreint six années
durant
[Musique]
ramsès 2 a sûrement été l'un des phares
en les mieux préparés à gouverner son
père l'a associé au trône
six ans avant sa mort il lui succède
ensuite à une époque où l'un déjà pris
l'habitude de s'assurer que les princes
héritiers ont suffisamment d'expérience
militaire et politique pour régner
[Musique]
dès l'âge de 15 ans ramsey s'accompagne
en effet déjà son père en campagne
militaire à 22 ans il mène sa première
armée pour réprimer une révolte en libye
avant d'attaquer en embuscade des
pirates méditerranéen qui s'étaient
risqués dans le delta du nil
sa plus grande bataille reste celle de
kadesh à la frontière du liban et de la
syrie où ils continuent d'affronter la
gigantesque coalition des armées it it
ainsi sethi 1er voit-il son fils devenir
un grand chef militaire est indigne
souverain un magistral ramsès 2 qui doit
d'une lucidité et d'une assurance sans
pareil s'apprête à laisser une marque
indélébile dans l'histoire de l'egypte
[Musique]
non
tous
[Musique]